بعدما اهلنا ابنته الف مبروك للعروسين
ولام العروس انت طالق بالثلاثه تداول
ارواد مواقع تواصل اجتماعي مقطع فيديو
لمصرينيو يطلق زوجته امام الحاضرين اثناء
حفل زفاف ابنته ما تسبب بصدمه للحضور
[موسيقى]
الا بالنسبه لام العروسه
لابنتها العروس ولم تتوقع حدوثه في ليله
عمر ابنتها وامام المدعوين
كما قالت انها كانت تعاني منذ سنوات مع
زوجها وانفصلت رسميا عنه في يوليو الماضي
مبينه انها فضلت البقاء في منزل الزوجيه
حتى ترعى ابنائها وتقف بجواري ابنتها حتى
تتزوج وتنتقل لمنزل زوجها ووصفت الزوجه
تصرف الزوج بانه محاوله لكيدها وذلك بسبب
حبي ابنائها لها مؤكده ان والد ابنتها
تسبب في فضيحه لهم امام الاصدقاء والاسره
والمعارف
[موسيقى]
من جانبيه رفض الزوج الذي يدعى نصر ويعمل
جزار الكشف عن سبب ما حدث منه وقال ان
الازمه انتهت بالطلاق واعلانه رسميا امام
الجميع ما اثار صدمه في الشارع المصري
واستنكار ما فعله والد العروس بقيامه
بتطليق الزوجه وكسر خاطرها خلال ليله
العمر لابنتها وامام الجميع